hi everyone welcome to 2018 the year of
web components before we kick off and I
hope this stage really stays because
it's shaking and so if you don't see me
move much that's mainly because I'm
afraid that this stage drops down let's
start with a question and I might might
see your hands I might not um hopefully
so hands up if you at any point in your
career had to write front-end code cool
that's pretty much everyone I expected
that but keep your hands up if at that
point you had to write a date picker or
custom select box at one point
all right that's also pretty much
everyone for the people who are watching
on the overflow room and you know that's
the problem right there like I've done
the same thing and in fact if you search
on NPM there's over a thousand modules
that solve date pickers and there's
everything from generic date pickers to
date pickers for react and date pickers
for view j/s and there's not just one
date picker for react but a million date
pickers for react and that's just really
complicated and you have like a big
amount of fragmentation because first of
all date picker implement implementing
date pickers isn't easy so why don't we
have a way to just use a date picker
like we use any other element that is
native to the browser like a video tag
or an input input tag like like a tag
textbox and this is pretty much where
web components come into play and the
ideas that we can use a UI concept like
date pickers just like that and over the
next hour I would love to talk to you
about why I believe that 2018 is sort of
where we want to look into web
components more and where they're really
going to take off and if you've been
around the web development community for
a while you might have heard the same
statement in 2013 or even in 2011 when
the web components idea was initially
announced however I really think that
2018 is really the moment where we want
to start looking at it and hopefully by
the end of the talk you're as excited
about them as I am but before we get
started let me quickly introduce myself
I'm Dominic I live in Berlin and I work
as a developer evangelist for a company
called Twilio where a cloud
communications platform so we have
different API for developers to sort of
different communication problems such as
sending SMS making phone calls chat
video etc if you want to talk more about
that we actually have a booth downstairs
so you can come by later ask me any
questions about the talk or also about
Twitter in general so I've been
developing for the web for a while now
and at every point in time so if we have
the same problem and that was how do we
share UI come UI concepts and in general
like UI solutions between projects and
there were different approaches
developed over this time one of them I
call the bootstrap approach so that's
basically you take a bunch of CSS and
HTML script that is typically hosted
somewhere on some CDN you blindly copy
paste that from the documentation
because you're like I think I need all
of them even though they say optional
but I'm not really sure which ones are
optional so I'm just gonna copy all of
them and once you have done that then
you go back to the documentation you
pick out your favorite component you
want to take and then you copy paste
that code and then the puzzling stores
so you want to have an alert box cool
your copy paste this but now the
question is so which ones of these are
styling related which ones are mandatory
which ones are optional which ones are
semantical which ones help you with
accessibility you know like and which
ones do I have to keep up-to-date at
which point you know is it do I have to
have the HR in there
or will the entire thing flip a table if
I remove it
what's mb0 you know like if you don't
spend a lot of time with that you have
no idea what that does where it's like
alert heading that seems sort of
reasonable but does that have to be an
age for can it be an age five because in
that contents their contact context
there is already an age four and I don't
want to I still want to have
semantically HTML so there's a lot of
these things that are kind of really
unsure and you shouldn't really have to
bother with so there's another approach
which is more the JavaScript API
is DK approach so in this approach we
load some global JavaScript and then in
this case the Google Maps API and then
we specify some way that it B is being
triggered so in this case we declare a
global function that is automatically
being triggered when the script has been
fetched and then in there we use a some
global SDK where we specify a Dom
element that has to be already present
which sort of acts like a container and
then pass some options in and magically
the SDK places a bunch of stuff in there
that we can configure while this is a
cool approach because it abstracts away
the things that we don't have to care
about there's a lot of things going on
here that are not really compatible with
modern web development how we do it so
first of all this requires Dom access
that's something that libraries like
react or angular really don't encourage
you to do because this will be very
difficult with server-side rendering for
example the other thing is global
functions we shouldn't really use that
and all of these concepts really don't
create a nice user experience here and
then there's another alternative
approach which is sort of like the share
button approach from Facebook and it's a
mixture of loading some global
JavaScript and this just looks really
confusing because they do asynchronous
JavaScript loading without using the
async and the defer attribute but I kind
of like just injecting the script
manually and one that once that actually
happened then you have to play somewhere
on your page some HTML that has to have
a specific shape so similar to the
bootstrap one by having a class in this
case FB share buttons so the SDK knows
what to look for and then you specify a
bunch of data attributes that then will
be read by the SDK and magically place
in this button the cool thing about this
is that we can have a fallback in this
case so if the SDK isn't being loaded in
this case we can put an a tag there and
that will just work however we also see
here that there's at this point we
already have duplicate code because we
have twice the same URL that we need to
keep in sync and it's very easy
kind of like overlook this so overall
all of these approaches what pretty well
if you're right playing JavaScript but
you quickly end up with a poor developer
experience when it comes to combining
this with frameworks like angular react
view pretty much all of them because it
requires you to access the Dom in a lot
of cases which is actively discouraged
and/or it requires you to load in a
bunch of copy-paste a bunch of stuff so
we quickly hand up writing wrapper
components around these things
however these wrapper components are
always kind of bound to the respective
framework where we want to use them and
that quickly kind of creates a
fragmentation in the way that we have
things that are out of sync different
features are in different different
wrapper components so if we look at
something like MDL which is material
design light so you can imagine that
like the bootstrap equivalent for a
material design so it has some global
style sheets and it has a global
JavaScript and people wrote wrapper
components around this and there's one
for pre-act there's one for react but
for some of these two even though
they're relying on the same boots like
bootstrap style library they have
completely different features they have
not only different syntax but like they
have completely different feature
coverage same time for view and stuff
and what if they kind of go out of sync
because like one of them is keeping up
to date with these security patches the
other one is not being used anymore
because it's driven by someone from the
community and they don't really care
about this anymore because they moved on
to another project so all of these kind
of really create a port developer
experience so what if we could instead
use custom like use elements and
components as if they are just native to
the browser you know what if we can
actually extend them from the built-in
HTML element and this is where web
components come into play and web
components contrary choose like a
popular belief it's just it's not just
one spec it's actually a serious of
specs so it's a series of four specs the
first one is called custom elements and
it's probably the thing that most people
associate with web component
so custom elements is this concept of
allowing you to extend the eight
built-in HTML element to declare your
own elements on HTML tags and when I'm
talking about extending the HTML element
I might I mean that quite literally so
you would define a new years 2015 class
it has to be an es 2015 class you can't
do the prototypal inheritance with
functions here and then inside the
constructor you can then kind of make
your own magic and kind of place things
into that attribute and start rendering
things and then later you just call
custom elements that define specify a
tag name and specify this class and the
browser will register this for you so
you can use it the cool thing is you can
also extend other built-in elements so
if you would want to extend the input
element instead you could do that you
would instead extend from that class and
then you would specify an attribute
called extends input to the custom
elements and both of these can be used
the same way you can use them as
declarative as you're used to via HTML
so you just use either if it's a normal
web normal custom element you just use
the HTML tag that you define and
otherwise if it's an extending one you
use that base tag and you write is
equals and then the name that you
defined and then you can also use them
imperative leave via JavaScript so you
can just use document or create element
and this is really cool because things
like the video memory act and pre act
like just called document or create
element under the hood and all of these
sort of libraries do so because they
anyways have to deal with things like
input and video and stuff like that so
there is no additional magic here that
it just works if we talk about custom
elements one thing you should keep in
mind when you're building them is a
difference between attributes and
properties if you're not familiar with
the difference basically an attribute in
HT is the ones that you define in HTML
and these can allow you to pass
information into a component but they
only support simple data so that means
we can pass on some things like string
or we can check if the property is
generally available we could sort of
stringify data and then
place it in but since we would
constantly have to parse it that's not
really performance so typically you rely
on basic data here and then there is
properties and properties are really the
properties on an instance of this class
so for example the value here the
equivalent would be a proper the
equivalent property would just be like
we grab out the element out of the Dom
and then call it value similarly for
like disabled but we could also pass
more complex data like an array for
example and the thing here is that these
two are not directly connected we can
connect them and we can make these
reflect reflect these changes and that's
what you would typically see with
built-in built-in elements but you have
to do it manually so it would look
similar to this
where you would define instead of just a
plain property you would define a setter
and getter and then these would sort of
take care of reflecting that change back
into the attribute
there's also lifecycle hooks in the HTML
element base class like attribute
changed callback so you can have listen
on when attributes changed and then have
reflect that back into properties or
handle events on this and stuff like
that
the next spec is HTML templates so that
allows you to create HTML that is very
easily easily and very performant Lea
duplicatable so you would use the HTML
template tag and then inside there you
can specify a bunch of different HTML
and CSS and things and they won't be
rendered so you don't have to worry
about that but the nice thing is you can
grab this by the query selector or
document or get element by ID and then
you can clone these nodes very
efficiently so we do that by grabbing
the content and then calling clone node
on this and in this case we're doing a
deep clone and then we can kind of
really easily stamp out new instances in
a very performant manner this is the
most performant way to duplicate the
same thing again and again into the into
the Dom because it's directly powered by
the browser
and one thing you see here is a slot
attribute and we'll cover that later but
this is one thing that you can use in
templates as well so then there's the
shadow Dom and the shadow Dom is allows
you to hide underlying implementation of
your custom element for example and
scope styling so a good example for this
will be the HTML video tag or really
like any of the built-in elements that
are not that are doing some styling to
it right because we want to make sure
that for example if you're overriding
the styles for every button the play
button on a video at the video player
shouldn't directly be influenced by this
and this is what the shadow Dom kind of
ensures the way you use it is you use it
in the constructor of a of your custom
element and you just call this dot
attach shadow
you in this case we're using the open
mode and you will see later how that
looks like and then we append just the
content in this case from the from the
template that we grabbed earlier we just
then clone that into the into the shadow
root and then that sort of appears like
this on in in the dev tools so the top
one is how we would write in a code
we'll create a date picker we could pass
in some child component and then once
that's rendered we actually have these
like the content that we pass in as a
child appear in the slot and it's not
going to be actually placed in there but
it's gonna appear at that position and
we again we're gonna see later in an
example how this looks like in case this
is a bit too abstract for you right now
and then there's the fourth one and
that's HTML imports and that's the one
I'm not really gonna dive into because
it's essentially declared dead the idea
here was to find a way to include all of
these things like HTML HTML templates
and and JavaScript and stuff like that
and and CSS all of that into into
another web site in an easy way and the
idea was well HTML already understands
all of these things so why don't we just
do a way to import HTML
in the meantime we didn't really see
adoption for that in the community so as
a result the team working on it kind of
like declared it dead and instead right
now everyone is focusing on JavaScript
modules there is the discussion around
HTML modules but they're still in a very
early stage so we're not going to cover
those so how does the support look like
so the support is pretty good if you use
polyfill so most of the things that I
talked about like HTML templates and yes
modules are actually in every evergreen
browser these days custom elements can
be actually really well polyfilled
shadow Dom is the more tricky one so
there is a polyfill called shady CSS
which will kind of try to do this
scoping of the styles but it there
there's just certain things that are
just not polyfill abble there so you
still have to kind of write very good
CSS there until until shadow Dom support
is there
however the polyfill certainly help you
to on board this quickly so that once
the browser's finish the implementation
your component just works so why should
you care why should I care why should
anyone really care about this so if you
develop a UI component web components is
definitely the best way for you to get
larger adoption if you're writing your
component for react only you're
excluding a large user base of view and
angular users and really anyone who
builds a static website there are still
a lot of use cases for static websites
especially in things like marketing etc
and even if you don't write UI
components for the world out there it
allows you to provide share the same
tools the same components among your
teams in your company
so if if you're working on sort of like
the brand guidelines and stuff like I
used to work at Microsoft and everyone
in the office org kind of implemented
their own version of the very same
button and this is sort of a lot of
redundant code and you kind of continue
doing that again and again every time
there's new brand can the guidelines
like on every department sort of use the
same button
and even if you don't fall in that
category like other people developing
web components and onboarding to web
components just creates a better
development experience for you as well
because every framework knows how to
handle native elements and therefore
that's always something that has a good
developer experience in every framework
to show you a good example of web
components I want to talk about a frame
so if you're not familiar with a frame
I'm not sure how many of you heard of a
frame all right that's not too many so a
frame is an abstraction layer around
three json WebGL and it's there to
enable you to build really easily web VR
experiences using simple HTML markup hmm
I'm gonna quickly show you a demo here
to show you where why this is really
useful so this is this is an A Frame
example it's some glitch and the link is
in the slide so I'm gonna share that
later if you want to play around with us
but we can do these things like walk
around and stuff and it's really cool
but writing this code in WebGL would be
incredibly complex writing this code in
three.js is still a lot of code and very
complex
however we looked at the code here we
see already there's a license file a
readme file and then just an index.html
there's no JavaScript there's no package
JSON there's no build pipeline there's
nothing like that this is all the code
for what we see and it's readable like I
can even if I'm not an expert on what VR
I know how to use this and I can go like
all right there's like Hello a frame
here so if I look back here it says it
there so I should be able to just go
here and say hello
let me see Oslo and we can change the
color here some let's I don't know make
this bright green so
stays like this and up loading
Oh anyways let's just keep this there we
go oh it was there Internet it's loading
so it has to fetch the the other
resources let's try this again anyways
but it's it's really easy to to kind of
understand how how all of these things
play into each other and even if you're
not an expert on this you're able to
play around with this another thing
another good example is a web component
my colleague Phil Nash Road which is
about the web share API and it's a
progressive component and I think in
highlights and really nice concept so
this is how you would use his web
component and it uses the web share API
which is an API designed to make sharing
things on the web easier especially if
you're on mobile and things like that so
you can just click a button it opens the
have shared dialogue that you're used to
from from native apps and you can
specify a bunch of properties here but
then he also allows you to specify child
components and in case web components
are not supported at all it will just
drop back to those child components
because the browser will just treat the
web component as a as a div as a div tag
so it's gonna ignore all of that but if
it does support web components and it
does support the web share API then we
will get an even better experience for
the user because they can actually get
the native share dialog
so if web components are great why why
and we've been talking about them so
long why didn't they take off yet and
there are multiple reasons first of all
browser support so it took a long time
until the spec was sort of finalized and
then the browser started implementing it
but it took a very long time like the
v-0 spec was around for a long time and
now we finally have a V once Baghdatis
be
implemented by more browsers than just
chrome and then the other thing is it's
a very low level API similar to WebGL
those were API that typically you
wouldn't want to write have the code
manually for because like I showed you
the example of how to keep attributes
and properties and sync and that's just
for one imagine you have to write this
for every other property of your web
component but the reason why we have a
low-level API has to do with something
called the extensible web manifesto and
that's a manifesto that is was created
by the all the browser vendors to kind
of agree on how they spec new features
for the browser and there are two
particular things in there that explain
why we work with low-level API so these
days the first thing is that they agree
on that they should focus on adding new
late low-level capabilities so that they
can create secure and efficient api's
because if they would focus on backing a
date picker and then ship that date
picker everyone would just complain
about like that's not the date picker we
want it to have you know like if you
like a good examples of select box how
many of you try to style the actual
build and select box it's not that easy
it's not what we wanted so instead we
end up writing our own anyways and then
these low-level low-level capability
should explain an existing feature such
as HTML or CSS and they should allow the
authors to understand and replicate them
and that's exactly what we see with
specs like WebGL which basically it was
like the accessing access to the
renderer or things like the the web
components API is which literally just
explain how every custom how every
native element is built like it's the
same way as how input tags how video
tags are built is how web components are
being built if you want to learn more
about that and why II like the specs of
the web components took so long that's
an entire talk by Monica that is really
great it's called how the web sausage
gets made so I highly recommend you
check that one out because I don't have
time to cover all of that and she did a
way better job
that so if it's a low-level API we want
to have great tooling because there's a
reason why we write tools around things
like WebGL so there should be great
tools around web components as well and
in the past this your options look
pretty much like this you wrote native
web components or you use polymer and
that was pretty much it
a polymer was the only thing really
driving for the adoption of web
components but the landscape these days
looks completely different so those are
just a few options and only some of the
options that actually have logos so this
is you can pick between things like web
components and polymer still polymer is
now in version 3 and drastically changed
from what they look like in version 1
and 2 and there their goal is to be
redundant at one point they just want to
drive the adoption of web components so
don't get confused something there they
just really want you to drive for
getting like building all your apps on
polymer they just really want you to
build web components but you can also
use things like glimmer which is the
rendering engine inside Ember so that's
the logo on the top right you can use
something like skate which is the bottom
left one it supports different rendering
engines from pre-act to hyper HTML etc
you can take your since the latest
version of angular you can start
experimenting with taking an angular
module and then turning that into a web
component so you can take multiple of
your angular components stack them
together and then expose that as a
custom element view does the same thing
there projects for react pre-act and
stuff looking into this there's also the
new kit around the block called stencil
which kind of made a lot of fuzz it's
built by the ionic team and there's a
bunch of these things and the the goal
here really is to allow you to pick your
favorite way of writing these things and
then sharing them with others so that
they can pick their favorite tools this
is not meant to replace angular and
react and view and stuff like that they
all have their use cases and they're
made for you to build complex
applications but they're not really
designed to share UI concepts with
others and that's really where web
components come into play and with that
let's stop talking theory and actually
start building the last date picker here
on stage to write a bit of history or if
I look at my time we might actually not
have enough time for that so instead
let's build a rating component because I
feel confident enough to do that right
now and before we start I need to give
you a bit of background if you if you've
seen my Twitter profile you might have
seen this picture so I'm part of a group
called one zjs we're just a bunch of
JavaScript developers who love the
community and also love wearing onesies
at events I didn't bring mine this time
but I'm typically wearing a panda onesie
so I figured I want to get your feedback
about the talk later so we're gonna
build a rating component that you can
rage how many pandas were worth was this
talk and or pretty much any emoji so
we're gonna call it emoji rating and in
order to build this we're gonna use a
tool called lit element so little
element is still pretty new around the
blog and is still in active development
but it's written by the polymer team and
it's just a simple base class for for
creating custom elements that is powered
by ledee HTML and I'm gonna talk about
that in a second but it's one of these
things that the polymer team is working
on to make the adoption of web
components easier without actually
having to dive into polymer it uses web
standards which means we don't have to
compile anything we will use module
bundling but that's simply because we're
using we're using base where you say I
forgot how they're called but the normal
module syntax that you used to use to
from note and things like that instead
of actually specifying fall paths if
you're not familiar with lid HTML it's
powered by tag templates so string
templates from JavaScript and it's
powered using HTML templates so that
means it's very efficient in re
rendering and creating multiple
instances if you want to check it out
that's the github repository and again
I'm sharing the slides later so you can
check out all of these things but that's
actually start building this thing
instead all right by the way just load
it again but reset the code um so let's
ignore this ah cool so that's the wrong
project nope it's also not the one this
is the one so I already have some code
but it's it's very much boilerplate code
so what I what I installed is I I
created a basic HTML here and what I'm
loading in here is the web components
jeaious bundle which is just all the
polyfills that we might need and then a
side of that I don't have anything in
here yet and I'm using partial to kind
of to bundle this during development so
we can easily test this so if I run NPM
start here it's gonna kick off parcel as
you can see here and start a development
server so we can click on this I'll
click there we go and there's nothing on
there yet because we didn't create
anything so if you develop with parcel
before or if you've watched Stefan's
talk yesterday you will know that you
can simply load any script here and it's
going to start the bundling for this so
that's what we're gonna do and if we
look into emoji rating it's been
completely empty files so let's start
with actually creating a class so we're
gonna create one called emoji rating and
we need to extend this from something
since I said we're not using HTML
element directly but we're using lit
HTML I'm gonna import this from the
polymer lit element module that I
already installed because I didn't want
to rely on the internet for this and
then we simply extend this from that and
the lead element expo has a sort of
interface you want to implement and one
of these is the underscore render
function so anything that's
with underscore in an inlet element will
be internal kind of functions and
everything that you add as without an
underscore will actually turn into a
method on the custom element later and
in here we're gonna return lit HTML
templates so the way that works is we
just write HTML here I'm gonna import
that from the tellement and then in here
we just write HTML and I actually have a
visual studio code extension installed
so I get full autocomplete here and
everything so you don't have to worry
about that but the difference compared
to JSX
is that there's nothing here that needs
to be converted later this would just
run if I would specify here instead the
path to the actual bundle I wouldn't
even have to bundle this it would just
run because it's using web technology so
I said we're creating a rating so we're
gonna create a roll range here let's add
a class called rating and for now let's
just write something like hello here to
see if it works and then we go back into
the index.html and we can start using
this so emoji rating safe this switch
back and oh so I created the class but
obviously I didn't tell like you tell
the browser about this so we want to do
custom elements that define specify that
it's called emoji rating and then pass
in which class should be instantiated
and now we have two hello here so far so
good now we want to have some properties
so we can customize this and the nice
thing about little iment and one reason
why i like using it is because that
element does the connection between
attributes and and properties for you
automatically and all you have to do is
define a setter called a getter called
properties and return an object here
that specifies which values of available
in what type they are so we want to have
a min value a max value want to have a
value
and then an emoji would be nice so we
can modify which emoji it is so that's
of type string and we want to have some
default values and that's what we do in
the constructor so we create a
constructor here need to call su persons
we're inheriting and then all I do here
is really set this to men there's max
choose five value to zero and because
we're gonna use pandas by default it's
panda here and now we have all of these
available in the render or we could just
call this dot on them but the render
method is also nice enough to pass all
of these in here so we can just grab
them and for now what we get just gonna
do here is put in the emoji here so
we're just using string interpolation
like any other string template would do
in JavaScript and now we have the Panda
emoji here so if we go back actually
change that here so if we open the dev
tools and we click on this this is how
it looks like right now so we see here
the shadow root because we're using the
shadow DOM and then in here is the HTML
we wrote and we see the Panda here if I
select this and I open the console down
here we have access to that so let's
store that as dollar zero and then we
can set the emoji for example two hard
toys for example and that updates
automatically you can see it doesn't
actually set it as an attribute because
right now it's only doing the reflection
in one way because that's typically what
you wanted to anyways but you can kind
of enable that as well if you want to
cool so we have that let's actually
built this as a rating tool so one thing
we need is we need a list of emojis and
I'm just going to do a small trick here
so this way we just get a the exact
number of emojis that we want and then
I'm using
since we're using lit HTML it has a
couple of helper library helper tools
that we can use one of them is called
repeat which is just really good and
officially re-rendering a list and we
can pull that in from the lead HTML
module it's actually in its own path so
that you're like they really want to
make sure it's a like small memory
footprint so you need to manually pull
these things in and then we're gonna
repeat here over the emoji list and
we're gonna have to declare a function
here that works similar to if you
develop with react the keys for example
since ours is anyway it's just a list
that doesn't have like any good property
that we can figure out on which values
changed just gonna listen on the index
and then I'm gonna pass in a function
here to render emoji I'm gonna bind to
this and then we need to define this so
call render emoji I'm just gonna get an
emoji and an index and then in here we
can return again some HTML template here
we're gonna call it emoji put an emoji
in here save this and now we should have
what did I break see to open this
nothing here oh yeah you should repeat
max and not value because will you zero
there we go now we have five pandas but
we want to obviously make this a proper
rating component so one thing we need is
a style just like a CSS class active and
what we're doing here is if the index is
less than the value then we're gonna do
the active otherwise we're just going to
keep our class and we can just use here
string interpolation again and we're
just going to write active and we're
also going to keep the index property
here for later and if we refresh this we
see that right now they all have only
emoji because none of them is active but
let's actually start having some style
here
so I'm not gonna write that and CSS
right now format this and this looks
already way more like a rating component
if we select this and we now do
something like value for exam we can set
it to four and we see we have four for
pandas but you don't want to ask your
users to open the dev tools and play
around with this to want to listen on
click events and the way we do that is
by and this is again similar to things
like react and stuff we can just listen
on the on click and then we do a
template here and in here we just write
like this and click we're gonna bind it
again and then we need to implement it
and we're going to get an event here and
our new value is going to be parsing the
event or target data set index which is
exactly the value we're setting here and
then we're just going to
to it and one thing I just want to do
for simplicity so you can also give me
zero Pender's if you want to I would be
sad about that but I want to give you
the option if it's the same value I'm
just gonna set value to zero and
otherwise I'm gonna set the value to
value save this refresh and now we can
start clicking here and all of that
works the thing though is that you also
want it like in a normal input element
you would be able to listen on something
like one change so ideally we should be
able to go here create a script tag and
say hey I want to grab the emoji rating
and then I want to add an event listener
for change and what I want to do here is
I'm grabbing the event and in console
logging event or target value so this
will work with an input element so why
shouldn't work with our rating component
so how do we implement that all we have
to do is I'm gonna turn this into an
async function because I want to wait
until the component has been rear-ended
and lit element actually gives you
render complete promise that always
resumes when the rendering has full is
always fulfilled when the rendering has
been finished and then afterwards I'm
gonna dispatch an event I'm gonna just
use a built in custom event called
change and then I need to specify some
detail and that's just gonna be our
value and I always put a semicolon there
for whatever reason we refresh this and
now we see it's actually console logging
the values that we specify whenever we
click here and the nice thing here now
is with this component we can for
example specify all the additional how
are your tags for example to make this
properly accessible and then the people
who use it never actually have to worry
about this like adding accessibility to
it it just works out of the
just like and first on one input element
would work out of the box what if I want
to style this so I'm using in here the
CSS custom properties or you might know
them as CSS variables and this allows me
to define a very clear set of things
that I should I like an API almost that
I allow the user to modify like I don't
want you to modify the entire alignment
and stuff like that I just want to be
able to allow you to modify how this
background looks like so we could for
something to give us a class called red
and then in here we can create a red and
all we do is we set emoji rating
unselected color that's the name I gave
it to rent we save this and now you can
see it's actually red for all the emojis
that are unselected and therefore
therefore we can expose kind of like a
direct thing and this is really nice for
teams like a brand team that maybe maybe
you want to expose how big a botanist
but you just want to do that via CSS and
instead of like specifying it in in the
HTML or you want to just allow you to
like change the color but nothing else
this will allow you to do that
cool so we have this I actually rolled
this up and published it to NPM so we
can use it later in an example but I
want to talk about something else that a
lot of people always keep on asking
questions what about stencil so if
you're not familiar with stands were
never heard of it
Stenson was written by the ionic team
and the ionic team basically creates a
bunch of UI tools for building hybrid
apps and they build stencil as a
compiler that generates web components
so that means contrary to what I just
showed you a little element they have
their own syntax they have their own
bill tool that you need to run this
through but then it will generate web
components and it's built by the ionic
team to bring ionic to more than just
the angular
because that was their initial vision
and then they started building
everything in angular and kind of got
stuck in there and now they want to bet
on web components to allow you to build
a hybrid app and to react to and still
use their tools for example and it's
heavily inspired by things from
different frameworks you know they took
some things from angular they like they
took some things from react like JSX
that they liked and therefore it uses
typescript it uses decorators it uses
JSX
if you want to check it out go to
stencil J's calm but I figured I'm also
just gonna give you a quick demo here so
we're going back close these two so what
I did is I literally just followed the
getting started instructions which is
get clone the following project and
remove the thing and then let's close
the disc for derp and then this is how
you how your structure looks like so you
get a default component here get an
index and HTML we're gonna NPM start
this to start the dev server it's gonna
do the first build and this is what we
see and if we look at the index.html
from this this is this is the component
we're using and the values and if we
inspect the component this is how a
component in stencil would look like we
have decorators which are still being
expect but they're heavily used by
things like angular and stencil and
stuff so they likely gonna not change
too much anymore and then down here we
have a render function so similar to
what we did with lit lit element but
here we're returning JSX so it's a
slightly different syntax so let's turn
this actually into my alert box because
we were talking about alert boxes
earlier we're gonna again do be a nice
citizen here of the web and actually
specify the role of this and we're gonna
create a title here you know have an
alert title
we can give it a default value like
alert and then pass it in here and then
I'm gonna use the because we're using
the shadow Dom here we can use the slot
attribute I'm gonna keep this and let's
add a paragraph before saying something
like hey something went wrong and also
add a footer like let's solve this and
then you'll be able to kind of prove
whenever you use this component you'll
be able to provide the details in
between these two if we go back into the
index.html we obviously need to change
this completely it's called my alert now
and then in here we can now give
information so we could put a div tag in
here and then inside we could put a
paragraph and say or let's do this like
a detail and then we write like Hello
here save this now we actually have this
details thing here and then in there we
have the hello and so far so good but
how does this look like now if we
inspect this we see the shadow root here
and we see the details thing that we
used right underneath it but then if we
open this entire thing we see the slot
and if we open the slot we see it
actually refers back to this property
here so why why is the browser showing
it this way why doesn't it just throw
this in there that's the way the shadow
Dom works and the reason why this works
that is that way is if we create now a
global style here and we say for example
we want to use cursive font and we safe
this will see that the paragraph that we
wrote in our own page suddenly has this
cursive fond but everything else stays
the same it's not being touched and this
works the other way around as well so if
we go into the my components CSS and we
say here as like hey every paragraph
should really be a fun weight of 800
it should be of color orange and we save
this we see again the other thing is not
being touched either so we have a full
encapsulation of the styles here and
that's that's the really powerful part
of the shadow Dom meaning you can
provide as a an author of a component
you can provide like these are the
places that you can play around with
everything else I'm controlling so you
can have multiple slots and name them so
that people can get a better idea of
like hey this is where I'm placing
whatever and therefore we then therefore
not rely on like oh I have to put the
things in the right order and things
like that cool so we have that one thing
I wanted wanted to show you is similar
to lead element there's a way to reflect
back the attributes so we can do here
true and now what this will do is it
will not only reflect attributes to
properties that will also do it the
other way around so if we grab the
component here and then do alert title
to like something
oh no we actually see that it's been
updated here as well instead of just in
the Dom cool that was the that was the
stencil demo now as a last thing I
figure we should actually use a web
component and in order to use it I built
this thing to vote on my talk later and
it's not fully done so this is the
deployed version but it doesn't actually
allow you to deploy it like vote
actually on my talk so we're going to
change that so the project is written in
angular it's just a default out of the
box
ng CLI project so I didn't do any magic
there I will show you two things that I
did
did you so this is the project we're
gonna start it off in the meantime so I
can start compiling two things I did on
the one hand I went into the TS config
where is it and I changed the target to
es2015 and the reason for that is that
types that
web components require you to do es2015
class inheritance you can't you can't do
prototypal inheritance you have to do
this because those are built in native
classes and not functions and therefore
you have to do this there is an adapter
if you actually still rely on down
transpiring to es5 there is a an adapter
that you can use but I wanted to show
you the like proper way that ideally we
can start doing this and then the other
thing that I did is in the index.html
I'm including again the polyfill and I
npm installed my component that I used
that I published which is the same code
like you can check it out on github if
you don't believe me
it's the same it's the same code so if
we go into app component module this is
where we want to do the first changes so
its first look if the app deployed so
here we go and open the dev tools and
enjoy dancing panda yeah so the first
thing we need to do is we need to tell
angular hey there's custom elements
around because angular will try to
verify that every component you're using
is indeed a component that exists so for
that they use custom they use schemas so
we can import the custom elements schema
which comes with a core library of
angular and then we just say hey
actually use this so from that point on
angular is not gonna bother trying to
verify that every component is an
angular component they might see like
hey there's one I don't know so I
believe that's a web component and then
the other thing we need to do in this
file or we could do it at any point
really but I'm gonna do it in this is
I'm just going to import the emoji
rating and that's all we have to do here
so now we can go into the app component
HTML and we can load in our emoji rating
here save it and if there's refresh is
we now have the component here all right
works and refreshes changes but if we
look into the app component TS we
actually already have a current value
property so we want to bind to that
especially because I want to set the
default value to three here so you're
hopefully more likely to upload my talk
so what we do is we do it like every
other component in H in angular works we
just say hey find this value to the
current value and this is how you do it
in angular to do the same thing in view
for example and now we see that the
Panda by default has three now if we
change it it's not reflecting actually
down here so it's clearly not updating
for that we can listen on the change
event and this is how you do it in
angular and we're going to create a
handle change function that we're just
gonna pass on the event - and that one
doesn't exist yet so we're gonna write
it and in here we grab the event and
then again grab the value this on a
event or target value similar how we did
it earlier with with a native kind of
add event listener and then we set the
current value to value one thing we have
to do here because some browsers based
on the polyfill the angular change
detection is still breaking but that's
not a problem with web components that's
a problem with a polyfill right now and
there's an open github issue too for
that so that's hopefully going to change
but in the meantime we actually need to
manually trigger the change detection so
I'm going to import this here and then
just say hey change detection detect
changes save this go back and now we see
if we reload this
hmm oh thank you it's nothing like crowd
debugging so now we can see it actually
have keeps it up to date down there as
well so let's go here remove these two
checks save it
[Music]
commit this someone else
just push this and cool so this is gonna
trigger off the deployment on net Levi's
and hopefully we have that by the end of
the talk in the meantime let's wrap this
up so I want you to think about web
components whenever you've realized you
have to share UI with other with other
teams with other projects sub projects
and stuff that's when you want to start
like hey thinking about hey is it worth
building this as a web component because
web components are not there to limit
your framework choices they are not
there to kill react or angular or
anything that's not the purpose of web
components it's just solving this
problem of actually sharing UI between
projects so we stopped writing redundant
code and actually can focus on quality
event quality things because ultimately
the goal is that you can pick your
favorite tools and let others pick their
favorite tools that's really the goal of
web components and hopefully to write
over one date picker to rule them all so
we can stop writing these at least have
one material design one or one with
another design philosophy and ideally
one that we can just style ourselves but
instead of having a thousand over a
thousand date Pickers
if you want to learn more about web
components and see some examples web
components on Orcas grade most of those
actually still use HTML imports but it's
still a good view of like looking at a
couple of existing web components custom
elements that everywhere is a great
website if you know curious of using web
components but you're not sure how the
support in your in your framework of
choice is because angular and view
actually have perfect support however
things that react pre-act still have a
couple of issues depending on what
you're trying to do with your web
components but the nice thing is this
runs against a bunch of different
popular frameworks it runs tests against
them and it also keeps track of all the
related issues so if you if you see
something doesn't work with it there's
likely to get up it should already
existing you can check what's the status
there and have Kievan keep up to date
with that if you want to compare
different implementations of web
components
there's a web component to do that has
versions for sketches for stencil for
view for angular elements on a bunch of
other things polymer so you can look at
like how the code changes which one
seems like the nicest philosophy for you
so there's a bunch of resources I'm
gonna I wrote a blog post how you can
get started and even publish to get an
urge NPM a web component with stencil
the slides gonna be on this URL and I'm
gonna tweet out all the URLs after this
talk the emoji rating code is here web
component org is our great resource and
custom elements everywhere and there's
the URL for web components and now let's
hope this actually deployed its refresh
yay so cool so yeah you can go to go to
this URL and vote for it there or you
can just throw in a Greens green piece
of paper and with that I would like to
thank you all for your attention if you
have any questions I'll be down at the
between booth most of the time so just
come by there have some ask me some
questions or ping me on Twitter my DMS
are open or shoot me an email whatever
you prefer and I'm happy to help you out
and answer your questions thank you all
[Applause]